this superhero sequel has more cameos
than you can shake a magic staff at and
a possible future for Shazam in James
Gunn's DCU this is the ending of Shazam
Fury of the Gods explained
one secret revealed early in Shazam Fury
of the Gods is that Rachel zeglers and
Thea is not in fact a cute harmless
teenage girl interested in the
affections of Freddie Freeman but is in
fact the third daughter of Atlas while
Calypso Works alongside her sisters for
much a fury of the Gods she goes on her
own to pursue the Golden Apple after
it's stolen by Freddie eager to set
their plans of Revenge in motion the
daughters of Atlas are coming to hunt us
when Mary Marvel attempts to fly away
with it Calypso chases after her on a
dragon and eventually drains Mary of her
power midair Billy is forced to choose
between grabbing the apple or saving
Mary as both tumble toward the ground he
wisely chooses Mary but this leads to
Calypso snagging the Apple for herself
after obtaining it she plans it at
Citizens Bank Park where the
Philadelphia Phillies play the Apple
gives rise to the Tree of Life which
subsequently Sprouts spreads its roots
far and wide and bears some awful fruit
small cocoons begin giving birth to
various mythological creatures from
cyclopses and minotaurs to harpies and
manticores they soon begin roaming the
streets and attacking citizens Calypso's
Revenge plans swing into full force
after Calypso plants the apple and the
tree unleashes chaos and Thea and
hespera start to have second thoughts
regarding their Revenge plans the
sister's only goal was to rebuild the
realm of the Gods which was diminished
when the wizard stripped its occupants
of their powers but seeing the Tree of
Life ravaging Earth causes them to plead
with Calypso to stop her plot Calypso
isn't interested in bargaining though
and sees her sisters as disposable as
hespera and Anthea confront their sister
Calypso's Dragon stabs hespera in the
back with Aspera on the ground dying
Calypso points the staff at Anthea ready
to drain her up her powers but before
Calypso unleashes its wrath she taunts
amthea declaring that it's a worthy fate
given her love of humanity Anthea tries
in vain to stop the attack but fails and
succumbs to the staff's power with
hespera and Anthea out of the way
Calypso stands alone the daughters of
Atlas are decimated by betrayal and one
villain remains
It's A Dark Day in Philadelphia with
most of the Marvel families stripped of
their powers and monsters wreaking havoc
in the streets only Billy Babson is Left
To Save the World by this point Calypso
has proven her power and has Billy
Running Scared Batson returns to the
wizard and begs the ancient being to
take his powers back in this Bleak
moment Billy feels like he was the wrong
choice to be the Wizards champion and he
can't bear the responsibilities that the
powers of Shazam give him I can't do
this
take my powers back you came to me so
you would take him back right but the
wizard tells Billy that his choice was
no accident he knows that the young
man's heart is pure and although he has
made mistakes he is the champion when
Billy gave powers to his family to turn
them into super-powered Warriors he
proved that anyone can be a hero given
the opportunity it gives Billy the
strength to form a plan to take back the
staff and end Calypso's reign of terror
it even inspires the rest of his family
to take action even without their powers
Philadelphia is completely overrun with
Mythical Monsters by the time Billy's
siblings arrive but without their powers
it doesn't seem like there's much they
can do however the group asks their
sentient pen Steve how to stop the
monsters and he points them in the
direction of the king of the beasts what
they discover is that the so-called King
is a unicorn which makes Darla
absolutely giddy the family then
attempts to find unicorns in a dark
Cavern however they aren't brightly
colored magical creatures bursting with
happiness and rainbows instead their
dark angry beasts that resemble horned
horses from hell as they try to figure
out what to do with the unicorns one of
them starts to charge towards Darla
before it can attack though she's able
to calm the creature with everyone's
favorite Taste of the rainbow Skittles
good girl
the sweet candies act as a modern
Ambrosia the sweet nectar of the Gods
with a unicorn on their side it calls in
reinforcements and Billy's siblings are
soon riding through town on the backs of
mythical creatures killing monsters
along the way
While most of Billy's siblings hunt for
unicorns Freddy sees and Thea walking
through a massive crowd and decides to
follow her Freddy catches up to the god
Justice Calypso and her Dragon begin
terrorizing civilians during the attack
Calypso spots Anthea in the crowd and
attempts to kill her and Thea is almost
defeated but Freddie manages to comfort
her and provide her with some much
needed confidence despite the morale
boost things look Grim right at their
moment of defeat Billy arrives towards
Calypso's attack and steals back the
staff the retrieval of the powerful
weapon is the beginning of the end for
Calypso with Stefan hand Billy notices
that it has begun to accumulate massive
amounts of energy he realizes that he
can use the energy as a bomb which could
potentially destroy the tree and
Calypso's dragon in one blast all he has
to do is lure the evil God and her pant
back to the stadium however before he
unleashes the power of the staff he has
to protect the innocent civilians who
could be killed in the explosion so he
calls on the help of the dying hespera
he begs her to use her powers to shrink
the magical Dome that has trapped him
for so long down to a smaller size so it
covers only the stadium trapped inside
the Dome Billy knows that he might not
survive when he unleashes the energy
from the staff but at least his family
and everyone he loves will be safe
not go fight for your family go fight
for the world everything is in place for
shazam's final battle before he takes
the fight back to Calypso he says
goodbye to his family knowing that he
likely won't survive his final
conversation with Freddy proves why he
was the perfect choice to be the
champion though he's afraid Billy is
willing to make his ultimate sacrifice
because he knows it's the right thing to
do he then puts his own spin on the all
or none mentality that has always been a
part of his family's heroics it's a
moment that bonds Freddie and Billy
together forever and proves that the
young man is a true hero okay I feel
like maybe I should be writing all this
down with a little time to spare Billy
flies into the stadium to destroy
Calypso once and for all but this foe is
more powerful than anything he's faced
before and this time Billy is all alone
but with his courage and confidence
returned he knows he has the power to
save the world he even has time for one
last superhero entrance he emerges from
a tunnel into the stadium with a display
fit for a rock star it's the perfect
moment to begin the final confrontation
as Billy enters the stadium for his
final showdown with Calypso he charges
the Dome with lightning the visual is a
callback to the Tesla lamp that exploded
in his room earlier in the movie which
is likely the inspiration for his final
attack and he charged Dome Shazam and
Calypso brawl the battle is fierce and
thrilling and eventually Billy detonates
the staff the explosion kills the tree
Calypso her dragon and himself Billy
makes the ultimate sacrifice to save his
family with Calypso defeated the Dome
dissipates and his family rushes in to
save him but Billy's wounds are too
severe Freddie in particular is
overwhelmed with emotion the wizard is
so moved by Billy's sacrifice that he
declares that his Champion is to be
buried as a god with anthea's help
Billy's family is transported to the
afterlife realm and there the young hero
receives a proper burial
Billy's tear-inducing funeral boasts a
Shazam lightning bolt etched in the dirt
on his grave site a somber family and a
sense of finality it also doesn't last
for long the wizard is asked about the
staff's power and if it could be
restored he says that only the spark of
a God could restore the staff's power
and that's when some unexpected help
arrives while the Wonder Woman Cameo had
been spoiled by recent trailers it
doesn't make her appearance any less
epic Diana uses her power to resurrect
Billy who Springs out of the ground like
a zombie everyone hugs him moments later
but just as importantly he gets to talk
to wonder woman who he has been crushing
on throughout the film Billy had dreams
of them on dates in Paris and now he
gets to take his shot at asking her out
it goes about as well as you'd expect
stick to saving the world kid it's
fulfilling to see Shazam finally
interact with other DC heroes in a
meaningful way and it's always a treat
to see Gal Gadot as Wonder Woman on the
big screen
now that the stuff is fixed everyone
gets their powers back and is able to be
a crime-fighting family again their next
task is to help rebuild the family home
that got destroyed when Calypso's Dragon
entered their world once their home is
rebuilt they can continue saving the
world together but they have a surprise
visitor one night as they're eating
dinner it's the wizard in essence
Diamond Honshu now looking like his
Dapper self sporting a handsome modern
look he tells the family that he's there
to take the staff and is going to start
exploring the modern human world he's
ignored for so long before he leaves
though Billy asks him one important
question what is his superhero name this
has been a running joke slash dilemma
for Billy throughout the film and at one
point 1970s Billy Batson actor Michael
Gray even calls him by the character's
former name Captain Marvel however the
wizard has a more fitting name for Billy
Shazam Freddy insists they could still
come up with something better
the first post-credits scene has Amelia
Harcourt and John economos two members
of Amanda Waller's team last seen in The
Peacemaker TV series walking through the
woods delivering some funny banter to
each other and saying that they have
come on Waller's behalf turns out Shazam
is being recruited for the Justice
Society it seems like the dceu isn't
ready to let Shazam be a part of the
Justice League quite yet but it's still
an upgrade to nevertheless Billy is a
little confused about it at first but
then suggests some fun alternative names
for the JSA of course it's tough to say
where this plot threat is going if
anywhere since James Gunn's
re-envisioning of the DC Universe is
still being rolled out the fact that
characters created by gun are involved
in the scene however suggests that all
involved will be heard from again
the second post-credits scene is more a
comical rehashing of the post-credits
scene from the first film than anything
that feels like a significant breadcrumb
but it is fun to once again see Mr Mind
One of the more eccentric villains in
the DC realm in 2019 the conclusion of
Shazam seemingly indicated that Mr mind
and Dr Savannah were hatching a plan
that would likely form the Crux of the
sequel since neither are found in Fury
of the Gods the obvious question is why
this time Savannah is still rotting in
jail once again Mr Mind shows up telling
him the master plan is nearly complete
Savannah grows angry saying he's getting
older Mr Mind responds that he can't do
things very fast after all he is a
caterpillar all he can do is just
Slither from place to place instead of
Mr mind giving any sort of glimpse into
what he's planning he tells Savannah he
has one more thing to do then slithers
away again is this just a pointless
catch-up scene with Mr mind and Savannah
or kicking the can down another couple
years until it finally pays it off if
this thread continues in the new DCU
perhaps it could serve up a plot for a
potential third shazam movie or even a
Mr Mind role as the big Baddie of the
Gods and Monsters chapter after all he
does run the monster Society of evil in
the comics
it's unclear what's next for Shazam with
the DC extended Universe potentially
being reset in the upcoming Flash movie
Fury of the Gods presents some potential
story lines for shazam's future with his
family's Powers being back Billy being
recruited for the JSA and Mr Mind still
being out there but it's unclear where
Shazam fits into James Gunn's plan if he
does it all while it would be
disappointing to sue Zachary Levi and
Asher Angel replaced after delivering
two fun films that have made the
characters a hit with wider audiences
both are getting older it's tough to
tell what's really in shazam's future at
the moment it's no shock that sequel
plans aren't confirmed yet because the
DC films are in such a period of
transition but perhaps some Solid box
office could make the case for more as
with any good superhero story there's
always a chance the hero could rise
again
[Music]
foreign